development is an ongoing process right  so actually the heart starts beating at  around 21 days  um and so a lot of women don't even know  they're pregnant then  um and the brain waves around six weeks  at eight weeks uh the baby actually has  um the 90 of the same organs that we  that we have as adults  so it's actually very surprising wait  say that again eight weeks from  fertilization so eight weeks if you  think about it most women find out  they're pregnant you know maybe they  miss their period and they find out five  six six weeks or so I don't even know  that so eight weeks that baby that or  that embryo has  um yeah has 90 of the same organs that  you and I have oh